these poppies are only a few days old
they're so tiny they're only taking up
just a little bit of space on my lap but
despite the odds that were put against
them they're well on their way to
enjoying life the way a dog deserves to
the warmth of mom and the softness of a
blanket to rest on
a big difference from where these
puppies were just a few days ago mom was
filthy babies were pretty brand new
Kimberly dumovich and Kenzie Payne often
go out to rescue dogs but earlier this
week they got a call from a friend
hiking in the middle of the desert near
di in South Hollywood as he spotted a
male blue healer daddy you followed the
dad and kind of led him to the mom and
it was Miles and Miles out into the
desert when they got to the location it
was clear the mom had just given birth
and was in desperate need of help as two
of the seven puppies had died oh my God
they're like brand new just baffles me
that
somebody would not even give them a
chance or drop them off so far deep into
the desert the dad came up to us and
started licking our face right away just
to tell us how grateful he was they just
let us carry them and they just let go
so they were ready they knew they needed
help after being rescued they got a full
belly of food a bath and a good night's
sleep then Mom and the babies were off
to a foster house you're such a good
Mama when you think of all the coyotes
that are in the wetlands I think it's
some kind of miracle that they're here
because it was cold and they can't take
that exposure
and on Wednesday The Rescuers who saved
the dog's lives were able to see just
how well they were doing the poppies
need to be with Mom for another eight
weeks and then they can be put up for
adoption Victoria Saha 8 News Now